alor this is some of our food that we
got um at hmart we wanted to do a haul
because that's interesting yeah this is
our hall here at hmart we're so
so
hip with the youtube slang thank you for
setting up everything in front of we
might get kicked out so we should
probably start yeah okay so let's start
with this one because you know this is
the ugly one okay this is a food object
this is a dessert
okay yeah do you want to get your
so
beverages
ready
a giant thing of seaweed that we're
gonna try
why don't you like things in your
it's so in my face how have you been so
big i've been great i've been um killing
it
in the game uh open for joe rogan last
week
was it good i made him laugh a little i
made him smile yeah i did a russian
accent i was like i was listening to his
oh really yeah
we can help you jordan peterson we are
in russia we will help you with your
problems with addiction we know in
russia we do things slightly illegally
but who's that guy that his it's his
friend and that he has a russian
epstein
friedman yeah lex freeman
not epstein at all
because because two of them are einstein
he's in the moment he's like you're
directly in the eye he's like a really
smart guy
those some of those spiritual people
like look you directly in the eyes but
and it's like it's like pleasant but
it's kind of annoying to me i don't know
because they they always like
feel like they're the best at doing that
they're like look how good i am at this
yeah look i'm in the moment
look how in the moment i am yeah and i'm
like i'm happy what the moment is for
yeah the moment is for relaxing dude you
never know like um what people look like
because
who is who's the president of canada
prime minister justin trudeau
he came to
we met him in person once and he was the
tallest literally most handsome person
like he looked like elvis young elvis
he's like on tv he looks on tv he looks
worse yeah he looks like a normal kind
of guy because you're like everyone on
tv is hot he walked in and he was taller
than everyone else like in there and it
was like he had these crazy like prince
eyebrows of just like they were perfect
like you know how prince and princesses
have eyebrows that go like this a lot to
look innocent
uh sure they're always like they're
always surprised looking
like oh my god i didn't realize i was
royalty
my innocence
but uh yeah she he was great uh justin
trudeau you know like will smith he's
like famous and like he spends millions
on health care and skin care like dude i
can't hear you you can hear yourself but
i can't hear you that well he
will smith looks like the perfect man
like yeah we are so used to normal
people but like wait non-normal people
are not that normal they're like super
humans
so this is a this is a kimchi croquet
it has kimchi inside of it but it has a
lot of other stuff too cheers
is this korean
yeah kimchi
that's good
yeah
it has like such a perfect level of
spice
ginger
now we can get the ugly bag off the
table this is like a beautiful setup
am i am i as good at this as riley is
i think you're on your partner
you're better at setting up food we
don't need food on riley's podcast yeah
you want to talk about animals like
riley does
have you ever noticed like giraffes
what chipmunks yeah they're like
squirrels but not really have you been
bitten by any of those animals yet no
squirrel chipmunk just a dog
dude squirrels and chipmunks will bite
this is yours
so this is our sake and mine is a
tanuki
that work
yeah
mine is gigan
did you hate doing that no i loved it i
love japan
so when they're raping are women so how
do you open this
are you like
are you like jealous of any of them of
any of the like maybe they're more manly
or anything japanese yeah
uh yeah they seem like a more masculine
culture yeah they're more like their
porn is so much better korean porn is
garbage
it's like way too much setup and the
girls are always like mean the girls are
always like
do better oh my god this isn't even good
they're like always like [ __ ] on the
dude it's weird
i haven't separated asian porns to know
who's making what
chinese porn is garbage
japanese are the best
they just know how to be creeps and
perverts but wait
who's doing the anime
where it's like
yeah
almost every anime show is porn
basically
like you watch it and you're like jesus
she's like
all the time no
i disagree
i don't know what anime you're watching
and then i saw like my first time um i
like googled an anime like porn thing
it was a gang bang that was like
non-consensual like all the male
students decided that the female teacher
wanted it but she never she always said
no the whole gang bang she was like i
don't know it's in japanese maybe she
was uh there was like
subtitles or something i don't know but
like so was it like an actual rape or
the whole time she was like
like a porn actress but like she started
to like it she was like but like
the whole time she said no japanese
people raped like
millions of chinese and korean women
yeah i know that just reverberates
throughout their culture
yeah they
they think the woman once is going to
like it at the end of the day
that's what they tell themselves so they
keep raping chinese women is it good
sake no it's all right
jesus
yeah it's fine
rice wine
can you drive after you drink a whole
one of these
yeah
dude zach bogus
was so [ __ ] wasted and he was about
to go drive home
i tried to like sober him up more before
he did
but he like couldn't even tell what was
going on he was about to drive home he's
still alive
today so
okay guys this is a
musubi and it's really cool because it's
like a giant
it's a giant thick
sashimi thing and this has
what is it
avocado and like ham or something
help
so i did the guest i was a guest for
kill tony last monday and i had a good
time i could have talked more
christmas yeah i should talk more
like you've been really good at being um
honorable and [ __ ] like
i was trying to like wait
yeah well you like wait to be asked like
he had to be like hans what do you think
and then you immediately had something
there
but if i was just constantly riffing and
driving then it might have been better
you never know because it's true that
tony
wants a certain amount of like respect
like
nobody knows where the line really is
like maybe i would have talked the whole
time and he would have been like shut
like he wouldn't have invited me back
yeah i just want to err on the side of
caution but maybe i could have talked
more
that's something that you could mention
to him if you guys talk about it you can
be like i think next time i'll talk more
i just wanted to be respectful i didn't
know what to do yeah so that he invites
you
yeah it's really tense i mean it's not
tense it's really nerve-wracking but you
said good things every time you talked
it was good so that's that's better
that's like the second best thing the
best thing is if i'm talking all the
time and i'm killing it the second best
is if i don't talk that much but i'm
killing it and the worst is if i talk a
lot and i bomb you just talked a lot
sorry
um
should i just bite into this or
i'm going to eat this
hans doesn't care about germs
just leave me one bite at the end
so we filmed a couple tick tocks in this
this h-mart hopefully they're good it's
my
it's my very first tick tocks that i
consciously filmed
as tick tocks vertically and everything
dude i had you on so many of my tick
tocks before you were anyone
yeah you were really like
people would comment like oh what is
hans like what is
this
no they'd be like who is that
and they would talk about like your name
they'd be like hans
and you weren't anybody yet
what do you mean you've been this person
this whole time yeah but now i'm
interested like say i kept
no
posting tick tocks of you now i bet
someone would be like oh i know who that
is oh yeah maybe one or two
i think this is spam i'm gonna
definitely spam three more bites spam is
good i love spam we need to rethink spam
you're from ecuador so you know no no no
no no no
we don't eat spam in ecuador
well you're poor we eat plantains you
eat whatever you get you [ __ ] spit
you heard that
yes i'm like here
no we in ecuador it's like plantains
like just
plantains ham cheese ham cheese
um yeah
plantains ham cheese that's sad ham
ham is not great
ham is like barely meat a lot of pigs i
think there's pigs there
nice like when you go to the small
villages
they'll be like a little you know main
street thing
and there's like giant pigs hanging from
ropes and people slashing them
if you're doing it
people
[Laughter]
yeah it's a lot of rice
this is what you want next
yes
but yeah i mean i saw that you uh
we have so much in common like
it's interesting because you know when
we both went down the coast at the same
time for two for two months and [ __ ]
whatever also like i saw that in an
interview you were talking about how
in college you got caught shoplifting
yeah and it like ruined you had to pay
off for a lawyer same
yeah i like shoplifted so much and then
all of a sudden
i got caught i'm pretty much an
ecuadorian princess in an asian man's
body okay
do you have like a sharp object or
something
how much did it cost like my family said
thousand dollars two yeah yeah mine was
a little bit more i think my family
skipped at christmas they were like we
can't afford a christmas
but they were just being dramatic yeah
they are always being dramatic
you skip for christmas but um how long
were you enjoying a [ __ ] play-doh
stuff for twenty dollars what i was in
jail for like eight what did you say i
just buy like a play-doh set it doesn't
cost much fun and then we like do
play-doh together yeah you don't have to
skip christmas like a [ __ ]
nazi family
yeah
but i was in jail for like
six hours
really maybe eight
was it a um group jail
yeah in atlanta balton county
were the toilets filled to the brim no
really yeah ours were nice is it all
girls
women yeah
okay it was we were in the medical ward
for some reason
were you all psychos or dude i was like
trying to be like friendly with the
police you know like
and the police goes oh what is she in
for prostitution like so fast
yeah he wishes
i didn't even know about prostitution at
the time
like about like normal girls being in it
like i didn't know that at the time so i
was like what the [ __ ]
like that's a huge insult he was just
like
wishful thinking maybe he thought dude
you're like talking to them i can't hear
you maybe he thought
it was wishful thinking look it's caught
on the rope right here
watching you okay i got mine
our country's cuisine all right i'll see
you in weed
seaweed
i'm so high man it's very fishy
wow i like it more salty
so like
fishy but i used to eat it with like a
sauce on it so it like kind of takes
away the fishiness
i uh it's hard to unseasoned it's weird
because they give you this bag and then
you have to like seal it up so you
either have to use it all right now
or like get put it in another bag ziploc
bags
yeah yeah maybe dude i'm gonna go get a
sauce
okay that's so funny you're just gonna
go get a sauce like you deserve it
do you see any sauces there's sausages
over there
okay christy's gone to go get a sauce
i'm gonna go sit in the sure seat
so
i think christy's
a little crazy but
i think she's also like super smart and
like super
logical sometimes
but also she's crazy as [ __ ]
and i think that's great because normal
people are boring
okay and we're back
do you want any of this yes
i got extra nice
oh my god
okay it's so good
you should have gotten a tissue
isn't this such a great place to do a
podcast see it's not bad yeah
with a song you want to wear this
the sauce makes it so good
yeah the headphones help
now you're going to see how much i
whisper
so this is what it's like to eat with
hans he just like throws up rice balls a
lot
rice is just empty calories
okay yeah i know i don't like rice i
think that's why asian people are so
skinny it's because they eat too much
rice
oh it makes me fat
um i mean maybe for a little bit latinas
get fat easily i've noticed i think we
have like the lowest
yeah because you're not used to sugar
i guess yeah
like every
hot latina like in high school and stuff
as soon as she's like 20
she's like way overweight
it's pretty hard
so these are assorted korean rice cakes
and those are
hodoki
so it's hole in it stop screaming pull a
hole
ella akbar
akbar
wrong region of the world
here
[Music]
it's funnier with headphones on because
you're saying allah akbar and then yeah
yeah asian equivalent would be dude i
mean like a
bonsai tree
yeah
is tsunami like a mean thing
tsunami means divine wind it's the um
it's the
it's the wind that swept the mongols
back to korea when they were trying to
kill me is that a wave it's divine wind
i forgot what it is like a when there's
an earthquake and there's a huge wave
it's like it's like a hurricane
okay
yeah yeah yeah it's a wave
because there's tidal waves in their
tsunamis
but try that one and try yours because
you said that white stuff all over my
face you said that this you thought this
was going to be better than this but i
think this is actually better than that
so let's see who's right
bean sprouts
green
ground bean
it's just the texture is so good it's so
soft on the outside dude it kind of like
has the texture of a snicker bar in
there
um
very thick jelly
okay
i was thinking like if y'all's bean
paste is so good
that's like your only dessert idea is to
put bean paste in things
where is the bean paste at what beans
are these
what beans is this i have no idea you
guys always hide it and stuff but you
never have it out
we're not a very bean oriented culture
is this a bean or is this beans with
sugar
okay that's 20 minutes
why 20 because your camera turns off at
30.
we can just see on the thing over here
but yeah i mean
yeah that tastes good
yeah but um
you don't even know the answer to that
so what was the question
what beans
where are all these good beans
nobody has them
it's not like kidney beans with sugar or
we make them into delicious paste and
put them in our ducks
we uh we don't just eat beans like we're
peasants we make something out of them
this is more beans
i didn't even try to find beef
stuff
it's just always beans which one do you
like better this one's good this one
literally is the same [ __ ]
it's good it's all the same
and this is this is the same thing as
this it's just ice cream version of this
yeah this is gonna be crazy how do you
guys do this
for thousands of years
what do you mean it's delicious
it's fine yeah
so
you know do you think that hippos
have like uh
smelly armpits
yes
because anywhere like the body touches
the body it's going to be gross because
it's like trying to be inside yeah
they're like trying to their bodies
yeah and it's just skin touching skin
where heat
is just hot and there's bacteria that
grows there because it's dark and it's
hot it's like perfect for bacteria
whoa
but uh do you think that like a fat
person's rolls smell like a bunch of
butt cracks
i think it depends
on how deep you go in
yeah and how how long it is since they
cleaned
yeah but uh
what do you think about doing a podcast
at this hmart food court so i think it's
nice that nobody's kind of bothering us
like yeah
when i first like i wanted to be a
youtuber like
two years ago or something like that and
um
i tried to like really be discreet
because i didn't want
you know i was just by myself like going
through like a walmart
and i just like i was kind of pretending
to just maybe i'm facetiming someone
like maybe this isn't
but people kept coming up to me and
being like what's your youtube channel
and just like trying like you're on
youtube this family
um next to me in the at the cash
register tried to get my attention but
like in a fake way like they tried to be
interesting yeah
and i'm
a [ __ ] so i like ignored them no matter
what and they started screaming
amongst themselves to try to be
interesting yeah and i didn't i never
looked because i knew and then so they
gave up and they just came over to me
and they were like what's your youtube
channel
that's nice
but what
if they're just like oh i'm just
interested in what you're doing i just
want to take part even though i don't
have any talent i would yeah i know i
was i
didn't like it though i was like
uncomfortable
i would tell them that this is just for
a school project i feel like you're a
person that values privacy
and you think it's respectful to give
people privacy but some people like
think it's disrespectful to leave you
alone and ignore you
yeah they're like i should come say
hello
yeah
and it's like uh
i just think it's crazy to distract
someone because like maybe i have adhd
and like maybe i don't want you to like
interrupt me yeah you know
yeah i mean everyone thinks that their
presence is like
not a bother but dude here's the biggest
one
have you ever had a cast you have a
finger thing right now but like have you
had a cast on yeah
when you have a cast on do a thousand
people ask you what happened yes
what do you feel about that
i feel like it's an interest they're
interested in you and at least they're
asking the alternative to that is them
being like i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you i hope your other arm breaks so
at least they're interested and it's
also like evolutionary like we want to
know what hurt the people around us
because that's how we might get hurt
so we like we asked them so that we
could be like oh
get hurt
yeah
yeah it's like when
it's like when you throw up people
around you start throwing up because
chances are you ate the same thing as
that person
it's like that it's like oh i don't want
to get my arm broken how did you get it
so that we can avoid that
that's interesting about the throwing up
thing actually
yeah
so why do you well how do you feel about
people asking you how did you break that
i don't happen i literally asked with
your finger and i think that's one of
the first times that i really asked
cause like if i literally see the person
every day
actually no because like in school i
don't know
if i literally talk to the person every
day then obviously i'm gonna ask because
there's somebody that like i literally
missed out on a few hours and then the
first thing you say
well
yeah then it's annoying it's like
whenever somebody if somebody walks in
that we kind of know
yeah i'm not gonna ask because i
consider the fact that that's an
annoying question right i know that they
have an experience and you empathize
with them and you put yourself in their
shoes but it actually like is bad
because
it's actually still polite to ask them
yeah so it's crazy like that's like one
of the biggest things but if it's the
first thing that you ask someone it's
sort of like
it surprises them it's not the best
avenue to for me to explain what
happened it's just very selfish it's
like you're not thinking about the other
person at all
whoa what happened to you and they're
like yeah i mean all day people have
been asking this yeah and it's like
remember that time you got hurt i want
you to relive it over and over again
yeah
it's like i don't want to be put in that
space right away all the time
do you think these all taste the same
pretty much
i'm just gonna pop it all in my mouth
this tastes different
but yeah they're all the same
i don't want the mochi ice cream now i'm
like sick of mochi stuff
i mean yeah
all right i'm gonna order some real food
wait i still have to try this one
this is basically like mochi ice cream
if it wasn't ice cream it's like
non-melting ice cream yeah
yeah
so my neck's been bothering me a lot but
yeah i noticed
you're always doing that yeah i hope i'm
getting better
have you tried
you know being upside down and stuff
like that yeah like downward dog i do it
a lot you actually help me even though
you're kind of a [ __ ] about it
you were like actually giving me good
advice and i started yeah stretching
like that it actually helps my neck more
dude there's
there's other things like little babies
walking like you said people in
chinatown walk
i don't even want to talk about it right
here wait don't you think asian babies
are the cutest dude when you pointed and
i looked it was an adult that was doing
that so i don't know what baby
there was an adult walking by stretching
the baby is walking all crazy
their babies are allowed to walk crazy
carrying a baby no there was an adult
walking by that was like moving around a
lot
we talked about that but i don't want to
discuss that here i feel like weird i
don't know do you want to float your
theories on asian walking yeah let's
talk about that like
in our pre in a private so what do you
think about hmart isn't it awesome that
we have our own mart like we found a way
to make a store and survive in
capitalist america
well okay but you you know it's like
what other country has you're selling do
you you're selling to yourselves
yeah we're creating our own ecosystem we
own this land now if there's a race war
koreans have a place to meet
look she's moving crazy is she a problem
the baby the child there's a child
that's like enjoying herself that's
funny
i love
children
because they can do whatever they want
and it's organic and authentic but
adults they're always like thinking next
step i remember how like sad it was when
i would ask my mom to play with me on
the playground
and your mom didn't know how to play no
she just goes like my mom was really
when i was a kid my parents were cool
they were like perfect for kids
but uh when i was a kid i'd be like but
come play with me on the playground like
legit play and she was like people are
gonna she was like happy but she was
like people will think i'm crazy if i'm
like sliding down the slide and stuff
um
and it was like true it was like so sad
though because i was like
what kind of a society is that
this is what i have to look forward to
even as a kid you were like you're like
wait so
at what age am i not going to be allowed
to play
never like you've lived a life where you
play all the time like you've purposely
engineered it that way dude and that's
what i like when i first started comedy
i was so bad like so [ __ ] bad at it
because
for my my whole adult life i was trying
not to be funny yeah like i was trying
really hard to be like very perfect that
was like my main thing is like i need to
be professional when i talk to like my
sister's friend or some friends or
something it's like they're not playing
the same game they're trying not to be
embarrassed not to be silly yeah they're
trying to be safe they're trying to
just not [ __ ] anything up and for me as
a comedian i'm never like what is the
safest thing for me to do it's always
just like what do i authentically feel
and how do i communicate what i feel to
the person
but also you want to be silly though too
yeah yeah
i mean i was being i was being authentic
but i couldn't be and yeah you there's a
lot of like authenticity that you can't
have also like i was trying to get a lot
of from i wanted to be like a really big
ambassador at the u.n yeah and so you
have to be taken seriously like you
cannot be like whoa i dropped something
again like you can't
you can't be like steve martin i'm like
a really naturally silly person and it
like it took
so much effort to take to extinguish
that of just being like what
yeah
yeah i mean what food is you laugh
really loud
i mean i uh i didn't when i was there
but i'm like trying to express myself
better like a deeper voice like you
don't want to have a high voice
i had a higher voice back then
yeah i was like
because like when you woo it's like
it's not like
i don't know
oh
even men that woo
they do a high pitch but you don't
exactly but you don't want to be seen in
that light you don't want to be seen
like as a woman sometimes or something
yeah i try to like keep it away because
it's a problem
um
but isn't that [ __ ] up that you have
to change yourself for the society
around you shouldn't you just be your
natural organic like self to this it's
hard for me to figure out what my
natural stuff was and by the way my
natural like when i was looking what
what were you as a kid that was your
natural self i was a tomboy
like a rice cake
you were like i was a tomboy solo went
on the monkey bars
yeah and like everybody knew christy is
a tomboy like this whole thing so
maybe that's my natural self
yeah when i was 14 this girl started
making me into a girl
you know that's a good thing
yeah that i became obsessed with boys
for [ __ ] 12 years
oh yeah boys are awesome
yeah boys will really
[ __ ] you with their dirty dick and then
break your heart as though you're
nothing
well it's another same with girls
i mean the girls are at least trying to
be like clean and nice i feel like i
don't know
have you met some dirty girls
yeah i mean i'm not a lesbian for a
reason
i don't know it's like an open wound
down there
it's like a wet
[ __ ] ravioli that you have to keep
from wrong yeah like dude um
sometimes on seeking arrangements the
thing they'll be like a hot couple who's
like looking for an addition
it's like you're going so you're gonna
have to have a threesome perhaps with
these people
and you might
you might be in a position where you are
being told to eat her out
as me
and so i like think about that and i'm
like that's so scary dude because what
if it's not clean like what if it's
gonna be relatively clean
and if it's like disgusting and then
what if i'm like
you know and then they all freak out and
they're mad i'm like no no no
you know it's like
and she's like what
you know
i don't know if vaginas are that
disgusting but you have a vagina so you
know the depths that a vagina can fall
into i don't think you have to clean it
every day like i don't know if a vagina
is that dirty the girl is going to be
like i don't want you to eat me out can
you like
gnaw my elbow
yeah i like clean myself i like go to
the bathroom and like just like i don't
clean myself before yeah you guys don't
you guys like pee all over it and you're
just like suck it i'm i sit down when i
pee i don't because if you stand up when
you pee you get so much dirtier holy
[ __ ]
i sit down when i pee i
why it like sprays out yeah
well this is closer to the [ __ ]
water so it doesn't splash as much
i showered today and i needed it shall
we glad i did it oh okay
how long had you gone i guess you go a
while you kind of wipe yourself like a
whole no
not really you don't even no one can
tell no one has ever told me
have you and kyle so kyle is this guy
who just ate a cucumber
out of hans's
blackened feet
and um the cucumber was someone's fake
dick before that for hours so the
cucumber was already a sweaty inner
thigh
cucumber
i don't know if it was sweaty
well it was on our internet and then
kyle and kyle's supposed to be like a
clean guy i don't know what
have you guys talked since then
no he did another bit where he was dick
cheney and he had like a chain i saw the
stick that was funny he was just doing
bits
what a funny
yeah i mean
i like him i think it's good to do funny
bits
but um yeah i mean there's a lot of like
boys in
austin comedy who are just like
himbos
what is that again like a bimbo oh yeah
but a dude well
none of them you have to be a himbo you
have to be pretty and gorgeous
and none of them are well you can still
be like
an idiot that only likes yeah you're
just a dumbass piece of trash guys are
so much more different than girls like
you can be a four and like talk yourself
into being an eight yeah like that guy
who um
yeah
i'm not gonna say yeah why are we
talking about specific people i'm not no
kyle's not a uh bad person i'm talking
about somebody else but okay so what
were [ __ ]
you were gonna go eat something i wanted
to eat one moshi before okay all right
let's do it just to be professional
we're doing it for the
the haul video because if we don't do it
then we're not respecting the art form
no
this whole place smells like trash i
think you don't know what trash smells
like because you're
you live in a dirtier car than i do
okay i live in a big old car
yeah sometimes i sweat like i'll be in
my car and i'm like sweating and my car
has cloth seats
so it's like soaking up my sweat and i'm
like [ __ ] this is not good i would pay
good money for that
yeah i i bought carpet cleaner so that
hopefully like i can clean the
seats i don't want it
han's like
i'm gonna get it myself
okay it's already melted
cheers dude
is it filming uh
do you know how to do it
is it filming now yes you have no
respect for like
what's most important and [ __ ] i know we
should have captured that because when
it blacks out people
people leave they're like oh it's it's
it's [ __ ] up now so you think
they think they're sitting down watching
unless for 30 minutes dude i don't know
like
i'm just saying that like i think people
have it on on the background yeah yeah
yeah when i have it on it's like on the
at the gym but like one of the first
times i had it on like i saw it would
black out and i'd be like oh most people
are gonna leave right now
i don't know
dude
try to be better
don't just be like oh it's [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] it's going to be [ __ ] like
i think the important thing to get
better at is having a great conversation
it doesn't taste good
it doesn't oh
it needs to be frozen or else it doesn't
taste that good
i'm gonna save it i'm gonna freeze it
so there you have it we had half melted
mochi ice cream we have these ducks
these are sorted ducks
and
yeah the outside needs to be frozen i
think
definitely
um and then we had some a little bit of
seaweed with sauce the sauce was bomb
i recommend bombs
i recommend sushi seaweed with sauce for
sure
nearly the sauce is like good with the
seaweed before that we have that uh
kimchi
thing
i'm gonna throw this away because i
don't want it
that's crazy you're gonna like eat that
yeah
i'm gonna sniff it
because you put your saliva to it and i
think you're really hot
yeah you're gonna like rub it on your
butt hole
yeah
and then i'm gonna leave it there and
let bugs eat it and just
let it get really dirty okay um
what else before
we
go
um comedy
is
a very useful vehicle to explore human
thought it provides positive emotions to
dark areas dude comedy like it's like
really good because um
it gives it it's it gives a safe space
for like anything to be talked about
right because you can be like
just know that like no matter where we
go with this we can always like back up
it's all safe it's literally like a
vehicle creating a safe space and like
whenever you have someone what that's
gay to say safe space yeah i know but
it's literally that's what it is because
it's a sturdy vehicle
it's like when tim dillon he'll go into
like really dangerous territories with
what he's talking about and then he'll
be like by the way this is a comedy show
so like it creates like if you don't
have that then you talk about dark [ __ ]
and you get negative and you get sad and
you're depressed but if you have comedy
you can go anywhere yeah there's nowhere
that we should be afraid to go
intellectually because if you have
limits in your brain then you're gonna
be stupid but if you're free then you're
just gonna be organic and natural and
fast limits man when they're like wait i
don't want to talk about that it's like
it's so
i keep making it so i love your filter
joke you should do your filter joke more
oh yeah i want to do it more i've been
thinking about it but hey it's weird
because i'm not racist
yeah that i don't want to have a filter
in my brain because
why do i need a filter like why what's
so weird behind your filters um
like we know some people who like aren't
comics and like don't really practice
comedy and they're always like getting
angry
they're always like getting super
serious
super cereal wait a minute dude i was on
a date with this guy and like he almost
like got to this point with me about how
you can tell who is a shitty person by a
house
yeah how they need to make it serious
yeah he started to say all this stuff
about how he is pro vaccine like but
like he started to get like very serious
and i was like hey hey like
i'm i agree with you man like i don't
know like
but uh
i mean it's important to
solve real issues and
yeah argument is important because a lot
of comics like to argue and i think
comedy and argument is like very similar
but it's it's like literally i feel like
this was the first time that i realized
how like it's a safe like the word safe
in it
the difference between comedy and like
an argument is that in comedy it's fine
it's okay
and that's the only difference yeah
it's okay and
it's actually great and it's probably
like where all the funny stuff comes
from is the dark stuff
people try to avoid darkness but
actually that's like
really useful
if your neck is bothering you now
it's going to bother you worse later
in your life that's why i'm waiting for
joe rogan to give me health care and
then i'm going to get into surgery or
you can get a
cell
end of the stem cell
yes
it costs like five five
five thousand bucks
hey uh did you see that i was struggling
to get i was like
yeah all the like rice cake is sticking
in your throat powder stuff i think
that's what it is
yeah it's like a bunch of gelatin that
we ate basically
every culture has like something that's
like
um
that's like uh what do they call it when
they put pork flour and cocaine
to like fluff it up yeast
well the every culture is like fluffing
their meals like hamburgers and
sandwiches it's just bread fluffing it
up so you feel full but the real meat is
the only food yeah that's why i eat only
meat i buy like chicken and
i've been doing that like ever since i
i just like i i i can't stand it anymore
the fluff yeah like the sushi it's like
a little bit of meat you start seeing it
that way yeah yeah you're like oh it's
everywhere this is all fluff and it's
what we really wanted is the beans i
mean it's the only way you can feed five
billion people yeah so it's like
bun efficient but it's not
the best for you individually yeah and
if you choose to do that individually
then it's unsustainable
so it's like what do you choose should i
just ruin my body for society or should
i just choose it's ruining like it's
making us fatter like it's not even but
yeah you guys do survive off of rice a
lot anyways i'm gonna go order some
jangmyeon okay
it's a chinese dish and it's very very
good
i think